something that really bothers me and
like honestly has given me a sense of a
little bit of an insecurity is the fact
that yeah like there are all these women
like throwing themselves but me like the
past 10 years like I don't have any of
that like I have zero this sounds weird
but like male attention cuz I don't want
it for who you're maror like why do
these women it's they're they wives and
mothers asking for male attention guys
at some point it's going to go all right
it's not going to last forever some Som
day every if you live long enough you
will be a grandmother yes nobody's
checking for Grandma I'm sorry not even
Madonna